how would you define a skank and and I
just as I came closer I realized you've
got tattooed breasts Madam so we do not
need that
definition my my Albanian friend uh
what's your name Florian that's
Beautiful Albanian and French apparently
Florian um Florian do what do you think
the most beautiful word
is what the [__] is that I didn't I
thought it would be English but no what
was
it to DOA TOA that's beautiful okay tell
you what I'm I'm interested in in words
because you you don't know this but the
reason I'm popular in Albania it's
because I'm a rapper that's my my actual
job why is that so funny to you Flor
like think of something fun it could
even be a whole phrase or an idea that
you want to rap about we'll get five of
those then we'll drop a beat and do a
freestyle and we'll get it super rapid
fire because uh you know it's the end of
the show we want to keep this [__]
rolling so Florian was like ah I love
you in Albania I'm like no [__] that
what let's get let's get one from here
that's not from
floran perogi perogi [__] oh Jesus
Christ it violates the food thing but I
will take it because you know we've got
to be solidarity with the Eastern
Europeans under the K of the Russians
right now and parois are some some tasty
ass dumplings what what stuffing do you
like in your parois potato potato potato
perogi the [__] whitest possible food
in all sense of the world get some pasta
stuff it with potato carbs carbs carbs
would you like some salt no thank you
potato parois lovely stuff this this
corner of the room what do you want to
wrap about broken ankle a broken ankle
oh I'm sorry so I presume it happened to
you how did you sustain it uh I didn't
you didn't oh are you out threatening me
right
now if this rap goes badly broken
ankle it's the hardest joint to
rehabilitate they teach us that at
Albanian daycare middle of the room so
far potato perogi broken anle call what
do you want to wrap about manetta Tavern
The manetta Tavern that's isn't that
like the place around the corner yeah
you do you work
there no just just a local drinking
establishment okay fine seems weird to
go to a rival business and be like n the
other one I mean you you've come here
okay this this corner what you want to
wrap up New York City May the New York
City marathon happening on Sunday right
yeah Jesus [__] Christ you absolute
losers you're all here I can't do a big
night on Saturday cuz tomorrow I've got
to run and [__] myself at the same
time Paula Radcliff represent um I
should ask my friend who said minut t
what's your what's your go-to drink
order when you're at the
bar tequila soda tequila soda I like
that you you had to think you like
should I say something more masculine
should I should I lie no tequila soda
Chris I I drink Ranch Water that's what
I drink but the girls over there loved
it they were they were like wow we
like
genuinely any single men or women go
over there uh final final suggestion
from this gang here what you w
about okay okay okay well unfortunately
you were bested by this woman who said
skanks um now I I'm not going to presume
uh what you uh how would you define a
skank and and I just as I came closer I
realized you've got tattoo breasts Madam
so we do not need that
definition
okay it's a lady of loose sexual
[Applause]
morals stick around after the
show really the women who cheer at
tequila soda they wish they could be
skanks they're nowhere near the level um
right this is this is what we're going
to do we're going to do a freestyle rap
about about all those things to remind
you we have potato parois we have the
manetta tavern we have a broken ankle we
have New York Marathon we have skanks
and then then and then it was it was ad
teda teda okay cool yeah that's what
we're going to do well um Gina do me a
favor and and hit that track this is as
I said a freestyle that's a wrap made up
on the spot B entirely on suggestions
not written not prepared not rehearsed
and do not worry it will not be anywhere
near as atrociously embarrassingly bad
as you're expecting in privately
educated middle class white British boy
to be this is how we end our nights in
New York City it's going to be it's
going to be
good I cross my fingers luck while I run
through you R spitting out to do her
yeah I really blew my load when I told
the lady that I love her I'm in tran
Albania I discovered that Albanian
ladies with the thick black hair i' be
like oh yes I can't bear I feel the pain
in my heart got confess my order I go
back home and I raid my L I say on
something you know me me cook it right
through so it's not too doughy that's
aogi yes I say so stuff it with the meat
[__] that the potato it's like an Irish
dumpling pump it in my face it's
thumping right down I be like chasing
this one West and another I eat a whole
damn plate and then I take a tequila
soda to the face like potatoes then
shots down from Tijana yeah I get a lot
maybe in wh hacker when I'm drinking all
of my tequila the Mana ta probably
serves it weaker than here this is the
place to get your booze if you're going
around there now you're a loser no
tequila solder I like when I'm asking
you didn't buff up and say a Manhattan
or an oldfashioned like Don dra if
you're running in the race then take
care you want to make sure that you pace
yourself and got a smile when you cut
the Finish Line 26.2 miles they sit you
down they're like the win against the
spoils nice night shoes and they cover
you in foil to make sure you recuperate
your body heat but if you stumble on
Sixth Street what you're going to do you
make sure you grab a handful of asphalt
stumble too much and break your ankle
like oh no it's robing when I'm on I
thought I would finish the New York
Marathon but I can't cuz I shattered my
shins I'm in such pain need to get into
the ER the doctor's in there he says do
you have Anthem Blue Cross Healthcare if
you don't you're going to struggle to
really pay sadly my man over here today
he didn't actually break it the
situation was not real he's just like my
imagination the ankles are broken that's
what's been spoken it's okay the last
thing that we're going to go in we're
having such fun from your naughty mind
you over here like yeah my friends of
mine are sitting over here they're
saying yo lady thank the last thing we
get tonight I'm going to shout out scans
a lovely little plosive sound hoay got
the SK an and another K two k's at a
third and it's racist but that's okay
yeah we can really face this you're
walking up saying yeah respect me I'm a
skank and I'm shouting out PR proud and
sexy I love to get my titties out love
to shave my ass people come in in there
like I want a tap I'm a skank and proud
I will shout it loud any guys around all
of you all are allow it's like a big
gang bang yeah you come and hang love it
when you're saying that Jesus Christ the
miks in the stand there we go Chris can
rap love a skanky lady in the baseball
C
what a delight you guys are lovely my
name's Chris Turner thank you very much
good night goodby